تحقق القوات الروسية هذا الصباح
مكاسب تدريجية أثناء محاولتها تطويق
المقاتلين الأوكرانيين في باكموت،
ووصفها الرئيس زيلينسكي بأنها واحدة من
أصعب المعارك حتى الآن على الرغم من
الغارة الروسية، تقول القوات الأوكرانية إنها
لا تزال متمسكة بالطريق السريع الرئيسي في المنطقة
المتنازع عليها بشدة.  المدينة
قبل وقت قصير قال وزير الدفاع لويد
أوستن إنها لن تكون
انتكاسة استراتيجية إذا قرر الأوكرانيون
إعادة التمركز في بعض المناطق إلى الغرب من
باكمود، وقال نائب عمدة المدينة لشبكة
CNN، إن هناك حوالي 4500 من
السكان الأوكرانيين لا يزالون في المدينة و  في
طريق الضرر، دعونا نحضر الآن اللواء المتقاعد
بالجيش الأمريكي مايك ليونز،
صباح الخير لكم، دعونا نركز على مسألة باك
هنا، لذا يقول الوزير إنها
لن تكون نكسة استراتيجية
لأوكرانيا إذا خسروا هذه المدينة، فهل هذا
صحيح وماذا  هل هذه أهمية
البكموت، نعم أعتقد أن هذا صحيح، وأعتقد أن خلاصة القول هي أن
كلا الجانبين يستخدمان
هذه المعركة لسحق الجانب الآخر،
وفوز أوكرانيا في هذا الصدد
بنسبة سبعة إلى واحد تقريبًا
انخفض بنسبة سبعة إلى واحد.  بالنسبة لأوكرانيا،
ما زالوا لا يملكون ما يكفي من
القوة البشرية هناك، وهذا ما
يحدث بالفعل على الأرض الآن،
الروس مما يمكننا قوله
يرون نوعًا من التطويق لمحاولة
تطويق المدينة هنا كنوع من
الدائرة الواسعة هنا، لماذا  ألم تأخذها روسيا
بشكل مباشر وسأخبرك لماذا يوجد
نهر تستخدم أوكرانيا
كمية لا تصدق من العوائق من
أجل حماية المدينة، هناك نهر
يجري هنا ولا يستطيع الروس
الإبحار فيه على الإطلاق، ولذا يمكننا ذلك  أخبرني بما
يفعله أي من الجانبين من خلال كيفية إسقاط
الجسور عبر الأنهار، لذلك على سبيل المثال،
أسقط الجيش الأوكراني للتو هذا النهر
مما يخبرني الآن أنهم يتراجعون
مرة أخرى إلى مدينة باخمان
ويأخذون هذا في النهاية، هذا هو
الطريق 504، طريق t504 للعودة إلى  لنفترض أن إيفانيشيكي
لكن الروس الآن يقومون بإسقاط
جسر هنا في كريموفا، لذا فهم يحاولون
منع الأوكرانيين من
الهروب من هذا الطريق هناك أيضًا،
لذلك نرى الآن ما
سيفعله الجانبان على الأرجح وما سيفعله على الأرجح
حيث ستكون أوكرانيا قادرة على تجنب
القوات الروسية لمغادرة المدينة، لذا
بالنظر إلى ما قلته للتو وكيف أنهم
محاصرون، إلى أي مدى
تعتقد أن القوات الأوكرانية قادرة على الصمود،
لذا يتعين عليهم أن يقرروا عدد
الضحايا الذين يريدون حقًا  كان
كلا الجانبين يطحنان بعضهما البعض
هنا في هذه المرحلة، وأعتقد أنهم
سيفعلون ذلك خلال الـ 24
إلى 48 ساعة القادمة وليس هناك
خسارة في ذلك بالنسبة لهم، كما تعلمون يتهربون
عندما يكون العدو أه.  أقوى في هذه
المرحلة، أعتقد أن هذا هو
القرار الذي يتخذونه حقًا، هل يمكننا
التحدث عن مجموعة فاغنر لأنهم
كانوا يقودون هذه الحملة من أجل
مزاج باخ، هل يمكنك أن تشرح لنا
مشاركتنا هنا، هناك مرتزقة يبلغ عددهم
حوالي 50000 جندي  نحن نعرف في
أفضل منطقة دون 10000 مقاول منتظم
حوالي 40000 من سجناء المستعمرات الجزائية
الذين اتخذوا هذا الاختيار
للانضمام إلى المعركة هنا لأنه على
عكس الجلوس في مستعمرة جزائية روسية
فإنهم غير مقيدين بقوانين
الأرض والحرب  تستخدمهم روسيا
للإنكار المعقول، فقد تم نشرهم لأول مرة
في 20 عام 2014 في شبه جزيرة القرم باعتبارهم
رجالًا خضرًا صغارًا، وهم ليسوا في الواقع
محاربين، رئيسهم هو
متعهد تقديم الطعام السابق لفلاديمير بوتين، ولكن هذه هي
الصفقة التي نراها الآن وهو
يشكو الآن من  يقول الوضع في
باكبوم إنه لا يوجد ما
يكفي من الذخيرة، لذا فهو يشعر الآن بالخسارة،
ويشعر أنهم لن يكونوا
قادرين على الاحتفاظ بها، وما
فعلوه حقًا بالمدينة الواقعة في
مركز رابلتون 4500 المتبقي من  ما
كان 80 ألف مدني لم
يتبق شيء، لم يحققوا أي
نصر حقًا، لذا بما أنهم غير ملتزمين
بنوع من القواعد التقليدية، فهل هذا هو سبب
مشاركتهم بدلاً من
القوات الروسية جيدًا، ويبدو أنهم لا يستطيعون حشد ما
يكفي من القوات الروسية  الذين يريدون القيام
بهذه المعركة، هذه مهمة انتحارية
مرة أخرى، هذه الهجمات الأمامية هنا على
المواقع وحرب الخنادق مع كل
العوائق المختلفة،
الجنود الروس أذكياء ويدركون
أنهم لن
ينجوا من تلك المعارك، شكرًا لك أيها الرائد
مايك، أقدر أنه من الجيد رؤيتك،
نعم، دعنا نذهب مباشرة لرؤية ميليسا
بيل تعيش لنا في المفتاح الآن، مرحبًا
بك ميليسا، القتال
مستمر منذ أكثر من سبعة أشهر الآن،
أتساءل عما إذا كانت أوكرانيا ستكون قادرة على ذلك
قلبوها واحتفظوا بالمدينة
للاحتفاظ بها لأطول فترة ممكنة،
وهذه هي استراتيجيتهم المجربة والمختبرة التي
رأيناها في مدن أخرى في هذه الحرب
حتى الآن على الرغم من عدم وجود أي منها في قلب
معركة طويلة لم نحاولها بعد  والصمود لأطول فترة ممكنة مهما كانت
التكلفة التي ستتحملها بقدر ما يؤدي ذلك إلى إضعاف
القدرة الروسية على مواصلة شن
هذه الحرب ومهما كانت التكلفة، فإن
القوات الأجنبية تقدم كل ما في وسعها للدفاع
أو ما تبقى منها بعد أطول
معركة في التاريخ.  حرب، واحدة من أقدم
المدن في دومباس، تقع في حالة خراب،
مياه ويرنر لم يتم اتخاذ أي قرارات
بشأن الانسحاب من باغمود،
لم تكن هناك تغييرات تكتيكية، نحن
نحتفظ بالدفاع
المهجور بأكثر من 90 بالمائة من
مسار سكانها،
غادر السير المكثف  القتال يعني أنه لا
يمكن الآن إجلاء سوى خمسة إلى عشرة أشخاص يوميًا
مقارنة بـ 500 إلى 600 شخص
يوميًا عندما بدأ الإخلاء في
نهاية فبراير وفقًا
لنائب رئيس بلدية المدينة،
ويقول نائب رئيس البلدية إن الروس يلقون كل ما لديهم على المدينة
[موسيقى] نيران
المدفعية الثقيلة ضربات جوية
والتزام كبير من القوات
البرية لكل من الجنود النظاميين ومرتزقة فاغنر،
لكن التقدم الروسي جاء
بتكلفة باهظة بعد إرسال موجة من الجنود الروس
إلى حتفهم
واتهمت أوكرانيا روسيا
بالمبالغة في تقديرها  يزعمون أنهم ما
زالوا يسيطرون على أحد الطرق السريعة الرئيسية المؤدية إلى
باهوت، وهو
شريان الحياة للمدافعين الأوكرانيين، حيث
غرد أحد القادة الأوكرانيين بأنه
لا يزال هناك العديد من الطرق للوصول إلى
المدينة. وقد
شكك المحللون في
الأهمية الاستراتيجية لباهوت، لكن ذلك لم
يوقف حملة موسكو المكثفة لتدمير المدينة.
الاستيلاء على المدينة
ولا معركة أوكرانيا الوجودية للاحتفاظ
بها.
لم يقتل وابل نيران المدفعية المستمر معظم المدنيين في المدينة أو أجبرهم على الخروج فحسب، بل
تسبب في
خسائر فادحة للجنود الأوكرانيين أيضًا مع
تحول المعركة إلى الأحياء المغلقة،
ويستمر قتال الحبوب في الشوارع.  إنها معركة شرسة من أجل
النصر حتى مع استمرار القوات الروسية في
التضييق على المدينة التي تعد بالفعل
مرادفًا للمرونة الأوكرانية في
ساحة المعركة،
الأمر الأكثر لفتًا للانتباه هو أنه بعد مرور
أكثر من مائة عام على نهاية
الحرب العالمية الأولى، إلى أي حد
يبدو هذا الأمر  مثل بعض المعارك المبكرة
لتلك الحرب، حرب الخنادق، المدفعية الثقيلة
وموجة بعد موجة من
الجنود عديمي الخبرة من كلا الجانبين يتم إرسالهم إلى
موتهم المؤكد، وهذا يحدث
في أوروبا مرة أخرى في
الخارج